[Musique]
les plus grandes affaires criminelles de
tous les ans un objectif trouver le
coupable le viol et le meurtre de cette
jeune femme et le sens qu il martelé les
temples aviez près
[Musique]
on a souvent imaginé que la fin du monde
ce serait le chaos la violence le vis
comme s'il reste et civilisé nos qu'à un
fil et que tous ces bons citoyens allait
subitement s'entretuer et d'essai libre
cours à leurs pulsions les plus vils
derrière le masque à l'abri du regard de
la société on a toujours imaginer que se
cacher le pire est décomposé lendemain
les ghana il est monté un mot xiaowei on
disait que le crime ne paie pas et
pourtant ça toujours été un succès
garanti
dans la fiction déjà il a toujours
attiré les foules il occupait même une
place de choix dans la littérature
quel que soit le genre il apportait un
moteur parfait à toute histoire le
frisson le suspense le choc et bien sûr
le sentiment d'injustice et la quête de
justice des gens qui ont pu avoir
mauvaise presse ces vraie littérature de
seconde zone accusé de flatter les bas
instincts piliers du roman de gare
débauche de vis et de violence tentative
d'homicide envers les belles lettres
est ce que vous croyez c'est une
littérature c'est simplement un
divertissement jetons pas les noms je
pense que je trouve en vacances
j'achète mon porte le voile le roman
policier un temps paru presque aussi
sale que les sujets du traité ce qui n'a
pas empêché de se vendre comme des
petits pains comme souvent ces oeuvres
mal famés ont été accueillis à bras
ouverts par la culture populaire avant
d'arracher ses lettres de noblesse la
loi écrite et celle du pot c'est pas
tout à fait mon opinion et un présent
que ces balzac qu'elle sait mon est bon
ces récits avaient envahi les étagères
et les écrans cathodiques malgré leur
noirceur
ou peut être grâce à elle justement
parce qu'il est allé fouiner là où il
était de bon ton de détourner le regard
parce qu'il retournait la boue dans
laquelle on patauge et benoîtement ans
nous éclaboussant au passage il nous
invitait d'une grande claque dans la
gueule à ne plus nous voiler la face sur
l'état du monde que ceux plus
c'est plus des romans de fait une étude
sur la société c'est surtout ça qui est
intéressant quand des gens ce plus
nobles voulait garder les mains propres
le polar retrousser ses manches et
plongez les siennes dans le camp bull
sans prendre de gants bien avant d'être
la violence et le vice le crime c'est
surtout un suspense une énigme à
résoudre et roulant toutes sirènes
dehors de fausse piste en 1 10 ou même
cantonné aux huit clos d'un intérieur
bourgeois impossible de lâcher son
bouquin ou sa télécommande avant de
savoir qu'il a fait mais le mobile du
lecteur spectateur à suivre pareille
histoire
donc c'est bien ce n'était pas juste un
insatiable appétit intellectuel un avoué
c'était plus sale que ça on était aussi
attirés par l'odeur du sang ne balle
près de cadars lune et andy bell l'autre
demie il ya donc eu deux agresseurs les
services de l'identité judiciaire ont
aussitôt alerté vont mêler largué il
yad'un côté voyeur dans le policier le
crime c'est ce qui venait nous déloger
de notre petit confort nous prenant aux
tripes dans notre fauteuil dans un
mélange de fascination et de dégoût
pas seulement avec une simple morne
aussi le macabre le sordide les
motivations les plus inimaginables et
les moins avouables
car c'est pour leur plaisir de ce crime
et bien d'autres seront communs j'aime
le frisson c'est amusant et excitant de
chercher ou qui va être tué et maman est
partie
et pour preuve le succès des journaux à
scandale et le goût pour les faits
divers
d'autant que dans ces cas là c'est pour
de vrai et si c'est pour de vrai c'est
encore mieux non ces choses horribles
commises hors des pages et de l'écran
dans le village d'à côté dans une
famille tout ce qui est plus normal en
apparence qui aurait pu être celle de
vos voisins ou la vôtre peut-être tous
ont reçu plusieurs balles dans la tête
seulement voilà cet intérêt pour le
crime non pas des criminels eux mêmes
mais des gens bien comme il faut
c'était plus souvent pour juger les
autres que se questionner alors
forcément il a plus souvent servi et a
exigé des châtiments que des changements
je suis une caméra de télévision qui
regardent pour vous à travers le monde
là où surgit le malheur on n'aime pas
que j'aie le dévisage on n'aime pas que
la mort d'un enfant j'appelle un fait
divers et parlera pas de l'audience ou
pour donner au public ce qu'il réclame
et les médias de masse pouvait prendre
la place de l'écrivain décrivant le
moindre détail transformant chaque mot
en gros titre traquant les protagonistes
jusque dans leur intimité parfois la
réalité pouvait se faire plus
incroyables plus chargée de suspense et
de rebondissements que la fiction les
faits rapportés par la presse peuvent
aussi faire office de feuilleton
avec chacun d'eux venu à la fois
enquêteur juge et bourreau en se passant
volontiers de compassion ou d'état de
droit finalement on était déjà préparé
pour la fin du monde
gnr de gier le pas léger investigue je
suis à la recherche de fonds ce qui
m'intéresse sauf que ce polar véritable
lui il n'était pas protégé derrière une
couverture ici l'opinion publique et la
pression médiatique débarqué avec fracas
chez les autres sans se soucier des
conséquences
les treize acquittés du procès d'outreau
vont ainsi être entendus par la
commission d' enquête parlementaire
cette journée d'audition et publie la
justice était devenu un safari attendus
du moment où on pousse jusqu'à son
extrême logique la loi du marché on
arrive la situation qu'on a vu autour de
la vologne dans la sphère grégory
victime suspect policiers jugés avocats
devenaient des personnalités publiques
sous le feu des projecteurs des
personnages pouvant être traîné dans la
boue ou portés jusque sur la couverture
des magazines mais justement le juge en
charge de l'affairé d'outreau fabrice
burgaud estime dans l'express ce matin
avoir rempli sa mission honnêtement vous
ai entendu il exclut de présenter des
excuses ce serait selon lui une solution
de facilité
c'est dans son appartement du mans que
le juge lambert a été retrouvé mort hier
soir un sac plastique sur la tête
marqué à vie par l' affaire grégory qui
lui a valu ce surnom
le petit juge dans cet appartement il
écrivait des livres beaucoup de polars
mais aussi des récits de justice en
espérant très fort ne pas être le
prochain don lévis serait disséquer et
ça ça avait pas attendu les canaux
hertziens les empoisonneuses avait déjà
fait les choux gras de la presse comme
landru
marcel petiot même gilles de rais était
passé de [ __ ] bien réelle à figures
folkloriques du mal ça arrange et bien
tout le monde qu'on nous fournisse comme
sa clé en main des monstres à côté d'eux
on ne pouvait pas être si affreux n'est
ce pas mais si c'était eux les coupables
alors c'est que nous on était innocent
et si le mal était puni alors tout
rentrerait dans l'ordre et on pourrait
continuer comme avant sans se poser de
questions lafon 7
chaque maire chaque pays a la gorge
nouée ce qu'on craignait de la fin du
monde sait que le vernis s'effrite que
les masques tombent et que plus rien
nous protège les bonnes gens des
malfaisants définit un petit si on avait
été honnête on aurait admis que c'était
de nous mêmes pour chercher à se
protéger le petit commerce aux biens mis
un jeune homme apparemment sans passion
qui ne peut pas être autre chose qu'une
sorte de mandat de malade mental mais
qui en auraient pu voir le crémant comme
le signe d'une société scélérate le
symptôme de nos dysfonctionnements et
corriger le tir avant qu'il soit trop
tard
mais on a préféré couper tout ce qui
dépasse plutôt que changer quoi que ce
soit parce que nous monsieur nous ne
sommes pas des gens comme ça
alors maintenant qu'il ne peut plus
cacher derrière les apparences de sa
belle civilisation
on va bien voir comment il se comporte
le bon citoyen oui la france a peur et
nous avons créé ces documents il faut
déjà que les combattre il je crois